now Adam you're you're fast becoming a
big star but I don't think a lot of
people actually know how you got the gig
it's airing out live if I got that job
oh wow I got the I just you know we do a
lot of impressions and stuff on the show
and that kind of stuff and I think I
auditioned one night I think the
impression that dad got me the job
everybody says this was the one that got
me was a Clark Gable's Butler I did it
everybody liked the way I did he'll be
here I sounded just like I'm all right I
guess this is Clark Gable father all
right no no he's dead
that's uh that was fun so why you got
any you got any new did you got any new
characters coming up this fall I had a
lot of time to think about it this
summer I came up with some new ones I
don't know if they're any good kicking
around it's the airport concession stand
guy Airport concession stand guy I say
that you need yeah yeah it's a well it's
a long way to go but airport concessions
that guy in it I don't know ask me do
you know a flight 824 left yeah do you
know a flight 824 left yet I don't know
how about a hotdog on mister it's called
mister I like rye toast a little more
than wheat toast guy yeah
and how do I help you with this one well
ask me I'm gonna ask you if you if you
got rye toast and you say no but you do
have wheat toast okay all right yeah all
right
hi how are you do you guys got any right
toast no but what we do have wheat toast
okay his first reaction was kind of like
you saw if if we played that bad guys
kind of like wow man but then I heard
you know yeah okay I'll go with shadings
in it this is one I feel like we'll be
the kind of character I do every three
or four shows you know this next one
it's called the guy who can't stand
grape soda guy the guy you can't stand
grape soda guy now when I go to take a
sip tell me it's grape soda okay what
cat what camera we're going to stay
let's stay on that one right let's go to
that one right there at right start with
the two with me and Conan and then we'll
switch to right there this is a guy who
hates grape soda guy okay okay
right because I that's grape soda
very good we've got a second but many
people opera man you said is was
inspired by a real guy on 57th Street
yes yes sings opera on the street yeah
and we brought him here tonight he's
going to come out and sing he's actually
the real guy that inspired opera man
that Memphis on a walk when Todd it's
leading toward an odd thing got me right
[Applause]
good buddy that sounded good good
challenge Larry its names Larry Danziger
and Adams gonna challenge him to see who
can sing the higher note
[Music]
I can't go anywhere 'is the winner
I always wanted to brew in America
we'll be right back with Dylan McDermott
[Applause]